reject nation the time has come to watch
stranger things season four part one last
season we had olivia with us but we are in the
middle of moving right now so she is doing all
the manhandling for that so i could enjoy
the show with you guys that's really nice
and she's working a full-time job on top of that
too maybe my part two should be back but anyway
guys i'm excited for this i rewatched all the
stranger things a couple months ago so i am like
i'm free to inject this into my friends let's
do this guys full length watch laundry sticking
with the time code will be over at our patreon
page for super sexy rejects cover a whole bunch
of shows and movies over there as well some of
the shows exclusive reaction highlights included
but if you can't do that please leave a like and a
comment that'd be very much appreciated also very
important subscribe and click that notification
bell to get notified when our next reaction for
stranger things is up because we're going to be
binge in this series so with that in mind we'll
probably keep the reviews a little bit short up
until we're at the final episode and then boys
at prepper you guys are helping us get through
all these shows in june so thank you let's do it
wow he's a smart individual none of
those words are the correct answers
it's probably brenner pop is back
if you didn't know that by
season four something's wrong
going through all the greatest hits
wow all the kiddos are you
up for some more lessons
oh ten it's supposed to be a dog
it looks like a cow you're gonna get
killed i want you to find dr ellis
why are they screaming
you should you should go there bro
that was the first time dr
brunner died and not the last
holy balls
whoo
oh my god wow
hardcore
so many dead kids so many mangled kids jeez
oh my god did she do it she did
it oh man what have you done
oh you're a murderer
yep there goes all my theories about seeing more
of the kids that spin-off we tried to do not at
all except for eight joyce says time is funny like
that emotions can make it speed up or slow down
we are all time travelers if you think about it
hint i have to make something called a visual
aid cool a little hop will is painting a
lot but he won't show me he's so much bigger
his funny friend argyle has been taking us to
school his hair is longer than mine and he and
jonathan like to smoke smelly plants together but
definitely not do cocaine miss you love out what
the hell are you doing it's ten after oh [__]
[__] 30 seconds okay i have to find my pants
got a hellfire club shirt i want you home no
later than nine tonight yeah okay i'll try no
no trying i need to go to bed early tonight
why it's a 6 30 flight nine or no california
oh i love her 80s trainer outfit
oh smart try tigers 86 tigers 86 copy that
do you see it yeah i see it oh no steady
easy i will repent later in latin rule what
a great girlfriend she returned five times
positive 53 minutes five seconds do you know
who pauses fast times at 53 minutes five seconds
i like boobies you like boobies we
all like [__] everyone loves boobies
they should have played the stranger themes
there will be a marching band remakes of events
think of heather think of billy
think about our heroic police chief jim hopkins
think about each and every one of our friends
let's win this game for them and that's
exactly what we do and i brought them all
back basketball save talks how is that
possible they call it a tournament if
you win one game you go on to play the
next until there's only one team left
god damn it lucas ah you're ruining the gang
again this is the championship game and this
is the end of eddie's campaign a semester
of adventuring has led to this moment and
we need you yeah and the tigers don't
you've been on the bench all year ouch
i'm tired of being bullied we came to high school
wanting things to be different i skipped tonight
that's all out the window just talk to eddie
get him to move hellfire come to my game please
oh man it's a lot to ask there bud be 25 in high
school is tough get all the support you can get
have you ever wished you could have the answer
to any question right at your fingertips
oh god yes it's just like those those big fancy
books you see on tv she saw an encyclopedia yep
in russia postage stamps you
come on let's go
call murray jane
so she does go by jane now will always looks
at her so much so much nervousness are you okay
i know you don't have powers anymore
still for my hero i chose my dad
and for my visual aid i made a dirayama
of our cabin more like diarrhea
i want to kick your ass so bad he made the
best eggos and we like to watch miami vice
i'm just like confused i thought this was a
presentation about a historical hero my dad was
in the newspaper your local paper that's not news
you idiot he saved lots of lives in a mall fire
so sorry mrs gracie i didn't mean to interrupt i
just wanted clarity on the rules of the assignment
that teacher won't just cut her off hell it
wasn't that bad friends don't lie i'm not lying oh
time for a heavy metal makeover millie bobby brown
phenomenal on this man so consistently phenomenal
uh what just happened does captain
basketball just break up with her
well she's working two jobs so it's not easy
it must not be easy for you either with your
stepdad gone it's kind of better honestly
better how not being abused but i know you
never want to go to any of my games but this
one is kind of a big deal a big deal lucas
you really care about this yeah i do but maybe
you should find something you care about too
oh buddy oh god david lucas people
just change okay that's it i've changed
ah ouch she's terrific you know how hard
it is for kids to understand grief sadie
sink man she's great too you're all right please
just go away are you deaf i said go away chrissy
mom you're ready to try on the dress again
i loosen the back a little for you what
oh my god
oh god it's like a freddy krueger like villain
this is our first taste of vector oh wow
literally feeds on your traumas at first
regarded as a heartless game of make-believe
now has both parents and psychologists concerned
satanic panic ritual sacrifice
sodomy suicide and even
ramirez in the ship lucas has to do his uh falls
and laundry baskets game so he's not gonna be
able to make it to hellfire tonight smooth so
me and mike we were talking shooting the [__]
we might postpone wow
i'm gonna snatch that diploma i'm
gonna run like hell out of here
yeah you say that last year and the year before
that yeah yeah this is different this year it's
my year what's going to say it looks like
it's 25 years there's a lot of older than him
yep well i'm here to tell you that there
are other little hostilities out there
who need help and all you guys gotta do
is get your peeps on and go and find one
it's like multi-level marketing
that's what real friendship is like
you received a doll in the mail he's a black
belt i'm sure we'll see his moves it's cracked
cracked yeah like the porcelain cracked
and they tried to glue it back together
okay okay uh do you have rope and something heavy
what for smashing all right hammer i was like why
rope yeah you want to drop something on it one
time come on i want to hang out with you and
eddie the freak munson uh yeah pass you're just
jealous because i have another older male friend
no no no
i hate high school
screw high school what oh we're going to
junior high to recruit she had lucas's sister
this is a good idea this is my normal walk to home
hello
fascinating hey sorry didn't
mean to scare you you okay
still hear the chimes
oh my god he does do satanistin it's time for a
ritual i do a half ounce for uh 20 what do you
say plenty of bang for your buck should last you
a while half ounce for 20. what a good deal jeez
middle school talent show you're doing this cheer
thing and i i was with my band corroded coffin
do you have anything stronger
satanist rituals i've got some dog
blood here that's the necronomic yeah
oh my god i am so sorry i hope mr fitly
is okay such a [__] the worst kind too
i cannot wait for you kids to die
did someone do this i tripped all right
angela oh we'll fix it together okay
i guess this isn't just wacky ass experiments
sure she's that lady in the neighborhood
i guess this makes sense because you
want some distance in case it explodes
we want to make sure that we destroy that doll
with as much force as possible one more thing
are you there talk to me
what happened broke do you
see a bug anything with wires
yes the riddler yes pop is a lie
who sent in the clues top speaking in third person
many managed to ship a box and
yeah must not be too oppressed
um we took a massively hard class
oh come on just tell her come on
sorry she was the girl talking about
in the bathroom that's right okay
let's do this
with the flag usa usa my name is lady
applejack and i'm a chaotic good half
elf rogue level 14. and i'll smile as i watch
them die we gonna do this or we gonna keep
chit chatting like this is your mommy's book club
welcome to hellfire
i'll probably never even know lucas was gone
we're saving hawkins all your traumas are asleep
sadness death killed my cat so it was
thought my friend so it was thought but vecna
69 dudes he only has 15 hit points left don't be
[__] [__] really cause we're not delusional
let's kill the son of a [__]
winners find a way to win
let me find a way chances of success a lot of
mirroring segments happening in this episode yeah
lucas lucas lucas oh come on do it lucas
and erica team sinclair james and claire
you're gonna be popular lucas
sinclair's crush
damn it was a cathartic couple
of victories right there
and now with tomorrow's assembly i'm gonna
take credit for how you made that three-pointer
and what a great game it was
alan ending with a dramatic
buzzer beater from bench warmer lucas sinclair
he must be feeling on top of the world right
he must love hearing us refer to
his benchmark she was listening
yeah first will last season was feeling
like he was being left behind with the group
what's got you all riled up good boy
this is uh my castle oh [__] yeah kick in pretty
quick oh [__] you sure you have it no no no
i got it um somewhere sorry i'm late sweetheart
right it's a warlock i have one of those
you're just like this guy i am this guy
hair down for all future reactions
a lot of messing with time in this episode
christopher nolan consulted on this
there's one person who knows how to do time
mom you're going to look absolutely beautiful
peaceful bliss just moments away
chrissy
oh fascinating chrissy hello
cool
she's gonna die isn't she
it's time for your suffering to end
oh god wow
all that judges dragons
man and the devil's lettuce
so much worse than i thought
that was so much worse than i expected
it to be that was that was damn
that was that was metal this show gets
violent but that is one of the most
violent things i think this series has done
that's disgusting yeah wow so painful and visceral
that was i was i was taking a
background violet that was yeah yeah man
whoa that's hardcore yeah that was brutal with
an umlaut over the you i like that these episodes
are so long they really take their time to
breathe like this is transported man oh yeah
oh yeah and it it's the perfect kind of
halfway point between a feature movie and it
just one of these is like five
minutes short of your future yeah
yeah absolutely but but at the same time this
was a great really lovely paced episode yeah
especially when you're going to introduce
new characters yeah you got to introduce new
characters you got to catch up with everybody
you got to set the stage and you got to build
the tension without going too ham too fast and i
thought they'd absolutely achieve that here and
i like the the new character or the new villain
you know like we've seen them before like i think
what's interesting is so much of the time like
every preceding season even the first season
every character's dealing with their traumas
and it's so much about overcoming their traumas
you know in order to to win the day and to have
a villain that specifically feeds on your traumas
is a cool direction to take your your
next villain in stranger things and also a
villain presumably from the upside down it seems
that um is also humanoid and humanoid to an extent
like uh humanoid and speaks as well versus uh you
know like incepting your mind or you know organs
yeah it is a it is a different direction
to to take it uh so yeah there's a lot here
there's more to talk about damn wow all right so
ideally we want to keep these discussions short
because uh but there's so much to get through
but they put so much effort into each episode
yeah that you want to like break it all down uh
yeah there's so much to to unpack here so you know
it's like and i know usually by the time people
are watching our reactions they're already like
like honestly they're done with the show
yeah they're already done with the show
you know so i get it i get it and and uh but
this this in particular for your pilot to return
it's there's so much depth in it and they
seem to be dropping a lot of clues about
time travel like a lot of us have suspected
that there might be some type of time travel
quality a russian doll already like right at
the beginning of this story and um you know edit
everything with the clocks and the way they called
how would you explain that that like when you're
cutting back and forth through a series of events
when you're intercutting like two sequences that
mirror each other in terms of yeah the action as
well as the sentiments spoken or whatever that is
yeah there's a lot of that in this episode i don't
know if it was to like get through the setup or if
that was a thing that was also thematically tying
in with the whole time element i think it is i
think i think there's definitely a time motif and
there's also definitely a sort of mirror's motion
it's okay this is this is what
dustin has to do with our dna
uh but yeah i thought that the there is a definite
mirroring and paralleling motif that they do
definitely within those montages and within those
inner cuts between yeah uh that sort of exquisite
corpse style like they're both basically saying
the same thing in two different scenarios but
there's also i think in a way where you know you
watch moon knight and it's like yes it's very easy
to tell there are million reflections and mirrors
and that's part of the motif but i thought this
also has that in the the visual in the settings
there are a lot of things that are played out
off of mirrors or glass or reflections and things
like that and and i think they lace those things
together visually as well really nicely along
with yeah the cutting and stuff like that if i had
one little um i don't even know it's a nitpick
because i i i want this is why you people binge
watch i want to wait to see how the rest of the
season uh unfolds is that after wanting you know
a season four for so long i was surprised how it
felt like most of the time was not spent with the
returning characters but with the new characters
yeah like they gave a lot of focus to eddie
like so much focus eddie and chrissy
yeah yeah that's about it everybody
but yeah it's like you have to edit it's not like
this is eddie's episode it really does yeah cause
you got a playset for the entire ensemble you
gotta establish some core conflicts and then
established to the new situation going and i
think yeah i'll wait to see how they do it but
for a first episode i did kind of appreciate that
because as the trauma you know continues and as
this villain dives directly into character's
traumas i wonder if they're going to now
kind of uh expand the themes into you know traumas
shared by communities and generational traumas and
things like that and other things definitely what
i was picking up on yeah because i talked to the
basketball player the basketball player to another
basketball yeah yeah absolutely that that really
uh leaned in on not sorry to control but yeah his
speech was very much about like hawkins community
yeah and so it feels sensible from here right now
that they would start that way and that they might
be bolstering the heft of the overall scope of the
story with that stuff but at the same time yeah
it hit me most when we cut back to 11 when they
uh in the scene that was released as a clip where
she runs into uh the bullies and they smash her
diorama uh like that was the moment where i was
like oh wow that's right we really are doing a
lot and we haven't seen 11 except for in these
couple scenes even yeah um so my my guess is yeah
the next one we'll we'll dive further into our
main ensemble again i mean gosh this creature
preys on 11's traumas there's an interesting
set up though you know to go from the early days
of dr brenner i don't know if it was ever made
clear that 11 was the one who offed the rest of
the kids part of me now is wondering if that is a
mislead or because if you look at the way chrissy
died and if you look at the way all the kids died
it's that same like all their limbs were twisted
and snapped around and so i wonder if it's meant
to look like eleven did all that when really
she might have been fighting fighting ah but i
assume they will eventually call vector yeah yeah
yeah i think they they said they call i think the
duffer brothers or someone said is yeah i forget
some details of what i've learned in the past
which if that's what they say about lucas being
on the basketball team i don't remember that that
was told or not if that was shown in trailers he's
shown in the jersey yeah is it yeah okay i don't
remember that now and for him to feel like there
is there is sort of an interesting migration of
that plot line of like ah every season one of
the kids is feeling especially alienated from
the group yeah i mean it's part of this goes
in theme with stranger things of growing up
you know yeah and i like the way that the the
tone and the 80s style is able to grow up with
them like this felt more like a teen summer movie
you know than perhaps like the the e.t or goonies
type of inspirations of seasons past i've i
thought i guess i get my dates all mixed up
i was like i thought that jonathan would be done
with high school now i know we're like working at
a newspaper in high school yeah that's not half
these people graduate oh never mind i guess i'm
getting my dates mixed up on because i don't
remember this last season took place in summer
i don't think they were in actual school it was
fourth of july yeah yeah you'd be in the midst of
summer yes yes yes okay so it makes sense and now
it's spring yeah okay yeah 185 days all right so
we're into everybody's last year that's right they
were working a summer job at the newspaper i was
just like i thought you were done with school and
now getting jobs yeah my memory was uh serving me
incorrectly but i got some fun little easter eggs
with tammy i remember now that they were talking
robin and uh and steve were talking in the in
the bathroom that one episode and they they
bonded over uh tammy yeah so you have that um and
then dustin's girlfriend coming back right away
not the last time we'll see her oh man no she's
gotta keep coming back but yeah i i do want moving
forward to spend time with the characters
we've grown to love over the years and like
really make that the focus but you know that's why
i said like it for for returning and to have your
episode length be as as thick as it is and for
all of them to be really long i think it's you
know if this was shorter i might have more of an
issue with that yeah um but no that was a gripping
ending you know yeah well it made really well what
was what was uh if i'm not mistaken when they get
transported to the upside down in the previous
seasons they they're actually transported even
when will remember what the rules are remember
when they went trick-or-treating in season two
in their ghostbusters outfit will was he had he
had uh the camcorder and then he got transported
and he fell down and then i remember uh mike was
like well where are you and he was like standing
right there he couldn't see him yeah so here when
they're transported it's all is within the mind
yeah it's like a telepathic link or something
like that oh that's crazy it's the sense that i
got yeah so it also mutates then the way in which
the upside down interacts with its hosts yeah i
mean we got uh we we got to catch up with a lot
more of our characters because there's a lot of
things we already have a lot of characters and now
we're introducing you always got way more than i
expected is more than i expected one isn't plenty
yeah obviously with a cast that's big you've got
a whole hellfire club yeah yeah and then yeah
all these other kids on the basketball and the
cheerleading squad i feel like the basketball
guy's going to be bigger and that's going to
lead to some trouble now with the whole freaking
yeah between lucas and his friends yeah oh no the
i was thinking the basketball player and and uh
eddie oh that too i mean yeah his girlfriend died
at the his uh yeah he's probably gonna get accused
of murder and oh my god the dungeons and dragons
yeah things are going to be really bad for yeah
for eddie pretty fast but no i i thought this
was i think what they said about wanting to
be more horror they really committed to that
um you know like season three got a little bit
goofy and a lot more comedic very junior year
yeah but especially with them all getting a
bit older too i think it's very natural to then
advance the grade of horror that they're willing
to go to yeah this feels more um yeah they always
up the cinematic quality and it feels more in tune
with like what we have with season one and two in
terms of tone and style and they can really take
their time for those character be like i love that
therapy scene with max like exactly and the scene
with eddie and christy in the woods was really
charming like you can yeah do all the play setting
you would have to do in like 45 minutes but then
actually give some time to also breathe and
some actual character endearment and some actual
emotionality into the scenes too yeah yeah so this
is character eddie is he older or is it he's been
like held back a few years yeah but he performed
for christie's junior high they were in the ad
like they were in school together and they did a
talent show and now that they're in high school
i think he's just been held back so much like
maybe he was a bit older than her maybe he's been
like two or three years held back or something
like that gotcha gotcha uh so but then again
yeah he has so many friends who
play dungeons just so many one
and i do appreciate the way that they cut that
montage between the dnd game and the basketball
game because i've never really witnessed a
dungeons dragons game uh and i'm sure there's
way more to it than even that and i know there
are a million web series where people do it on
camera but this was one where i was like i really
love that they're cutting back and forth between
these two things and giving me some vague sense
of how this all works and it does look pretty fun
it looks time consuming but it looks really fun i
used to love a good imagination game and there was
a line um that i remember in season three a line
that was that could have either been taken one
of two ways with will of i forget exactly what it
was but a lot of people were like did he mean that
he just doesn't care for girls and he just wants
to hang out with his friends or was he implying
that he's actually gay and then they had that
moment there in the classroom where that girl
tried touching him and and uh playing footsies and
he was like get away from me see i don't know what
to think now yeah because i feel like almost that
they want us to think he's gay and then they're
gonna reveal him as somebody can't have two gay
people two gay characters they're gonna review
maybe they'll hey i mean maybe they'll reveal
him as asexual that's the thing too that doesn't
get brought up very often might as well make it
happen but it almost seems like something else
is happening that we can't because i feel like
it would be very easy to go uh maybe he's gay
or else he just doesn't like that particular girl
or whatever well nelly bop everyone's great still
millie bobby brown excellent as always uh she's
just such a like she's my favorite character um
a lot of people said like she's an easy one to
her hopper the easiest ones to go to but uh no
specifically her like her acting is just so
unbelievably phenomenal oh yeah the little
nuances about her her speech and vocabulary and
all that stuff like i will say my association
with finn wolfhard has definitely changed over
the years i used to see mike now i see finn wolf
throwback extraordinaire very aware
of finn wolfhard that's my goal for
the czar so everyone else i just see the
characters even one node of writer i just
i just see finn wolfhard that's my biggest hope
for this season is that it can get me back to just
seeing him as the character because so much of
what i understand about finn wolfhard is just mike
yeah well the first two seasons i i saw mike and
then for some reason in season three i'm like i
don't know why i'm just aware of like i feel like
you're playing mike but you're you're not really
mike yeah yeah because i've seen so much of finn
wolfhard in my life and all these other things now
well and so much of him is very similar
to mike anyways so i feel like the lines
kind of have to blur i don't know if you're
writing like interviews and stuff he comes across
a little like cooler confident actor kid yeah
but it's but it never seems like man he's really
created a character here like i i feel like the
things he do not to like i feel like he's not as
nerd i feel like mike is so much more nerdy and
and like when i see interviews and stuff he comes
across like i'm a little cool but i feel like that
sarcastic and that quick wit is still in there
sure sure yeah you know just just yeah i still can
film all four he pleased ghostbusters after life
i mean fair enough yeah yeah yeah the guy who's
like i want the guy who specifically says i want
bill hader to play the older me oh hey could you
imagine if stranger things did an it thing where
eventually we see them all as adults maybe you can
make it out get that it casting right back in here
yeah i always like him and i wouldn't want the
show i don't want that to be a misconception i
wouldn't want this show without phil wilvardo
no he totally dna yeah yeah i would not feel
the complete without him 100 um yeah and i am
worried jonathan will still get a little bit
pushed to the background again like yeah it
was last season hey they'll find something
like that to be important they're setting up that
they're gonna find flaws in their relationship
i guess that's the thing i i don't know i feel
like yeah the most interesting thing they had
was like oh she's gonna choose him over steve and
then the rest of the time they're like okay cool
how do we make jonathan engaging now yeah season
three wasn't that engaged i loved him in the first
season and i really liked them a lot and carry on
in the second season but yeah third season he was
definitely pushed a little bit to the backdrop so
yeah i mean they're all everyone's still great and
uh we we've got long ass episodes for a reason and
you know anyone who didn't really spend time with
i'm sure we're going to spend time with them in
other episodes do a whole episode on argyle alone
yeah this is but for a setup it still managed
to feel like incredibly engaging and different
it does feel more late 80s yeah yeah yeah which
is i think is a really fun it's a very specific
part of the 80s it's late 80s yeah yeah and i
mean some people claim 86 and 87 specifically
is some of the best years for pop culture ever
and so they they definitely come with distinct
and yeah i feel like yeah you're
reaching like peak 80s at that point yeah
all right guys well thank you for being
here keep a lookout for our reaction in
the next episode we don't know how these are
going to be uploaded we got a lot of shows
so yeah just bear with us as we're going but
hey we'll just keep a lookout and last but not
least let's let's shout out some patrons
archangel gabriel alexis venus and serena
williams mitchell reed you do good deeds t he
he nmb jimmy burns i want your ashes in a yearn
alan ling playing with my thing logan
burton my butt's hurting from all the
twerking you did for me i hope i didn't overuse
my rhymes don't fear when you got kyra eric cons
39 you read my mind when you decided to
pledge do you see cousy cousy because i see
cousy cousy phil eider i'm no longer in
dire and i will call you my sire bearer
in the garage not in a lodge because bears
are from the woods nick x you are the bats
i get euphoria when i think
of juan longoria gail ferguson
jaren wanner bon von milano cliff rodriguez
i'll do it if you tell me to suck on your eggs
chris brings me loss of bliss busting nuts and
stuff master t you're a real g who brings me a
lot of glee fanny i'm in heaven with john the goat
seven pseudonymous entity i love you for eternity
will you please join my fraternity yeah
and burn with me whoa yearn for freedom
guys and girls and everything in between i want
to thank you all for being part of our patreon
page and show your support at this specialty
um a little bit helps right now especially
now you're hiring a lot more editing hours
these days so thank you guys so much keep this
real rejects train chugging along with the
help of you guys oh you guys suck with you soon